they've got a lot of things wrong in
that they expected that there would be a
revolution in energy so that we would
have jetpacks and flying cars when when
we got instead were a revolution and
information which led to cell phones and
laptop computers energy is limited by
the atoms and how they interact with
each other and the chemical binding
between them unless you're going to go
nuclear whereas information is pretty
much limited only by our cleverness in
how to store and transmit it the
information revolution was enabled
thanks to the developments of
semiconductor and solid-state physics
which in turn were created or made
possible thanks to the discovery of
quantum mechanics quantum mechanics is
the branch of physics that deals with
how atoms interact with each other and
how they interact with light back in
1926 Hugo Gernsback publishes the first
pulp magazine devoted exclusively to
science fiction amazing stories also
publishing in 1926 urban short anger
publishing the Schrodinger equation that
would form the foundation of quantum
mechanics so there's these two visions
of the future that start off in 1926
really within months of each other one
leads to the fantasy world of death rays
and the other leads to the reality of
lasers